I seem fun the diary of Jen Kirkman
podcast episode 213 coming at you from
the all things comedy studio that's
right this podcast is a part of the odd
things comedy Network go to all things
comedy calm and watch and listen to all
of the other amazing content and
podcasts that they have there if you are
watching again you're just watching a
recording of a podcast and Casey's
blurring it's yeah that's what you're
watching someone record something that's
meant for audio so that's on you alright
oh my god there's so much to talk about
well first of all I've already recorded
episode 212 and I'm deciding that this
is gonna need to be 212 because I'll
explain what I recorded to you in a
minute I I can't even believe I thought
it would be listenable but my tour is
over tour is over if you want it as John
Lennon said that was war is over if you
want it I know can I not do it where's
the part this was gonna be so good and
we're gonna get it we're gonna get this
right okay I also like saying Trump is
over if you want it that's a good one
that's I'm gonna make don't steal that
I'm making a sign that's gonna here it
is
[Music]
and I do want it I want my tour to be
over because I'm tired but I'm still
traveling twice more this month for
personal for personal things I'm
actually going to see don't yell at me
everybody Amy I think I'm actually going
to see Hillary Clinton speak in Portland
Oregon
again easier sometimes to go there than
go to anything in Los Angeles and look I
know Bill Clinton was part of the
Epstein sex plane I get it I mean this
way I feel you know I listen when [ __ ]
comes out about everybody and if I find
out bad stuff about her I'm I'm you know
I'll say it too
I will say this do I love some of
Bernie's ideas absolutely that's why I
was a Bernie bro originally years ago I
think he behaves like I'm lunatic and
then something's up with that guy
Hillary what I could get into it but I
think if you want to know more about her
her book what happened is great now
don't get into this bit do you mean Lee
believe everything she says like if she
says I was here on this day and this
black woman was my mentor and that's how
I learned to start a foundation for
children like yet that's not a lie you
might be like I still don't like that's
fine but you know there's facts and
there's not so I enjoyed some of the
facts about some of the things she's
done but anyway you know I I don't know
what's gonna be coming out about this
Epstein guy and I know Bill was on that
plane I don't know I'm really hope that
Bill Clinton did not have sex with
teenage girls I really hope he didn't
but we're gonna see what's gonna happen
and I don't know what Hillary knew we're
getting political right away we're
getting crazy but I just wanna say we
don't know what she knew and we don't
know that you could blame her for why
she knew something and didn't say
anything why she didn't know what I get
it I just want to keep it nuanced and
focused when it does come out in many
ways I feel bad for what people don't
understand about like how feminism keeps
growing as we women learn a - and she's
an older woman oh I did a gig with
Gloria Steinem this week I mean it was
underwhelming I'm gonna be honest with
you but I explained my you know I think
back in the eighth in the 90s when she
said on a stay home and bake a cake all
the Republicans were like oh and then
you know so she was like oh I get it
stand by my man work with Republicans
how you get ahead and then nowadays it
would be like are you crazy you leave
the guy and you blow it all up to uh
she's always a little bit you know not
quite in the thing anyway that's not
what I want to talk about I just wanted
to you can complain to me later that I'm
gonna go see her speak um and then I'm
going to New York City to spend my
Christmas
I'm completely I don't know how to put
it but I'm in completely in such a
recovered place from my dumping of last
year my life is objectively better
subjectively objectively both it's
actually both better this year and I am
not mad at my ex I just I think they're
just I don't know if I it's not about
that it's about me and so I am excited
to be in New York on Christmas I will be
still I think writing this script
because we're a little behind so it's
gonna be kind of a working Christmas
it's basically my life is going to be a
hallmark movie this Christmas I'm in New
York City working busy businesswoman
except when I'm in New York it'll really
be New York and won't be empty and I'll
be wearing a coat and a scarf I just
watched a hallmark movie the other day
where this woman this little kid wanted
to put his scarf on a snowman and this
woman was like his mom was like he'll be
freezing no you keep the scarf for you
but her the mom's friend this woman was
like you can have my scarf and she takes
it off and her friends like it's gonna
be in the teens today and she's like
it's alright and she's literally wearing
an open very light will coat no scarf no
hat nothing like if it's in the teens
I just cannot they're getting so
flagrant in them now now they're telling
you the temperature in the movies and
and still telling you we're not going to
put our characters in any kind of
anything it's almost like everyday Trump
tweet something more insane and
egregious you're like how is he getting
away with it we can't even start with
hallmark movies how are we gonna contain
him you know people just live live life
in our face sometimes and we we just
it's become the new normal that Trump is
president and that people when
in the teens they don't wear scarves
hats or gloves and they have no socks on
in high heels in the snow I mean it's
just that's America that's what it is so
anyway this is episode 212 if you like
the podcast even if you don't just
[ __ ] throw me a bone go to iTunes
write a review give it 5 stars and
subscribe and the review this week can
be I am not wearing a scarf that's what
you could put as the review so that when
people read the reviews they're like
what does that mean again bauble bar I
have my own jewelry line this necklace
says feminist AF you can get a ton they
don't to be about that cat lady it's one
that says single unavailable taken
laundry day they say all kinds of fun
things and again they're custom it and
my head is blowing up I did a gig this
weekend and I raffled off some of the
necklaces because the money was going to
Planned Parenthood in Oklahoma City and
people were like can I get one that says
this I'm like no this is what it is
these are the necklaces these are the
necklaces you go online and custom make
them do people not understand this
concept that that that that they
understand in other areas like you go
pick the colors you want and the word
that it says I can't make 17 thousand
versions there's 20 colors and 14
expressions and then two different kinds
of metal and then lengths so that you
know do all those maths am I going to
carry around 5,000 that's not it's an
online store because there's no overhead
does that make sense people we it come
on 2017 no overhead it's all online it
ends December 31st I have three weeks
left to be a small business entrepreneur
I know you think oh she'll just pop up
somewhere else and I'll get it then no
literally no one is going to work with
me again in the professional world of
fashion because I didn't prove myself
with this because I was too political
and Twitter for them so I [ __ ] myself
I guess and but that's okay not really
that's really not why but mm-hmm
my mom's probably think oh my god I
can't even discuss I can't discuss and
my parents lack of understanding of
politics and what's really going on they
literally are not getting the news my
dad loves Trump I don't I can't I don't
know I don't know
he thinks Robert Mueller is legitimately
a bad guy I have no words I have no
words I'm like the Republican in my
family now I'm like Richard painter said
like I am following all the
conservatives on Twitter I'm like he's
amazing
that's George Bush george w bush's old
ethics lair and his tweets are out of
the park if you guys don't even bother
engaging your family about Trump but if
you want to or if you just want to know
feel sane go follow a bunch of
conservatives on Twitter that are
against him and it'll make you feel
it'll make you feel normal anyway so get
the goddamn necklace bauble bar kombi au
ble ba r dot-com homepage of my website
has all the info you just missed some
big sales I tried to warn you about it I
tried to and but I would get them now
for the holidays because sometimes it
could take a couple weeks to ship but
the women that saw them in person and my
little raffle thing we're loving on them
people love the necklaces they love the
over-40 alright so there's that follow
me on at I seem fun podcast on Twitter
and Facebook calm down for the listeners
at home you might want to check out the
Facebook page within a day or two and
you will get the link for watching this
because I'm recording it as well but you
can also go to youtube.com slash ATC and
then you can search icing fun and you
will find some of the live recorded
episodes and if you want to email me
it's I seem fun at gmail.com and the I
don't give a [ __ ] tour will start in
2018 touring again I'm tired
but I will be doing some comedy club
dates and they will be I think some
things are on sale right now I have to
look I've been so [ __ ] overwhelmed
reading the script and on tour and doing
50 jobs and so I have to make it to do
list to do find out what's on sale when
with 2018 okay so but if you go to my
website Jen Kirkman comm you can see
where I'm coming Caroline's New York
City I'm coming in January get tickets
now that's fun if you saw me in New York
already that series some new stuff but
it'll be a repeat but it'll be totally
different it's a comedy club environment
so
you might see me work a different skill
set today's episode is brought to you by
talk space texture and Casper we'll get
into that in just a moment all [ __ ]
right here people I think that's
everything I wanted to say Oh London
tickets are on sale for London that
Saturday night show the third was sold
out then they just opened up a couple
more seats so I guess it wasn't sold out
but they don't tell me that they're like
we hold seats mom so I would come see me
in London all shows are the same but
earlier in the week is when the
reviewers come so I could really use
your assistance in laughing really I
never get good reviews in London anyway
they they don't they don't hate all
American comics but I would think they
would like me because I'm a
conversationalist and they'd like that
there but there's always some angry dude
who's mad at something and not cuz he's
a dude I'm just saying those have been
the reviewers so far they they hate it
Ron Funches like a lot of Americans get
bad reviews there that you're like
you're clinically wrong we are very
funny oh okay I hope everybody's
watching the marvelous mrs. Mazal on
Amazon show that I consulted on and oh
my god I watched it i binge dydt this
weekend it's so beautifully shot I'm
just I can't believe I got to work with
Amy sherman-palladino and Dan Palladino
they are they are brilliant they are
brilliant people and this is one of the
mirror I'm gonna talk about miracles
today miracles so you know I'm naturally
not but I'm just gonna start in with
this I had such an amazing miraculous
year and I think about I used to be very
like I think I did a podcast episode
years ago that was like I don't want to
be the old woman who just has fans and
isn't in a relationship and you know I
was like Henry likes just some gay guys
she pays to live with her but I look at
things so black and white it's like just
because I had a breakup with this
particular person it doesn't mean that
when I'm 90 I will only value fans like
I'm not like that
like I'm also fine without a
relationship right now I don't desire to
be in one but if I do again that's great
and if I don't for some reason like I
never find anyone to want to do that
with which I'm messing in a negative way
like could you know everything's a
possibility I could meet five people I
could be married five times I could be
this but my life is so deep and
meaningful that someone else could only
enhance it not like make it what it is
and I think in the past I used to think
like Oh relationship makes her life what
it is and I knew that even when I was in
my last one that it doesn't but I wasn't
quite skilled at it yet so now I'm
really getting it and anyway so my point
is that it's okay actually to love your
work and to live it and breathe it as
long as like I tried to do good things
this year with with my job like doing
some charity shows for hurricane Harvey
relief Planned Parenthood oh my god my
Christmas show at the [ __ ] Hollywood
improv this Thursday it's the Jen
Kirkman dysfunctional Christmas show
we've got Sam pancake on it my friend
Chris fringe Ola Alison Costello Brian
Huskey I'm gonna interview a couple of
those guys have been in hallmark movies
we're gonna show clips and talk about it
throwing candy at you singing Elvis
we're gonna raise money for the LA Food
Bank I'm also asking everyone to bring
an unwrapped children's book because
there's a Barnes and Noble book drive
for the poor children and I love doing
stuff like that so I try to do
charitable things throughout the year
with my shows when I can and you know I
in my own personal life there's a lot of
hippie dippie helping and spiritual [ __ ]
going on so I have a very fulfilled life
and so I never I can't believe I ever
thought that work was something I should
hide or be ashamed of her don't get too
into it cuz you don't want to be one of
those like Hollywood weirdos is alone
it's like I'm not alone I'm and my life
is giant and there's so many people in
it and again as I said things are deeper
more meaningful with my friends than
they were in the past that now that's my
tendency when I'm in a relationship I'm
like this I come home I tell you
everything that happened that day and
then I'm I'm not telling anyone else oh
my god now I got to tell this person
that story and that person it's like I
didn't know how to spread it around and
um that's not why my breakup happened it
was it was more to do with my ex and his
issues in his timing of being in a
relationship with them but you know you
look at like well maybe what could I do
better next time with him or someone
else I don't mean with him but you know
what I'm saying like you could just do
better next time doesn't even have to be
specific to that person
my point Annie whoo so that being said
one of the miracles I had this year and
and I'm telling you people I know you
might not like this suggestion but if
you want my holiday suggestion if
whatever as as Chevy Chase says in
Caddyshack there's a force in the
universe Danny you know you're gonna be
the ball and whether that force in the
universe is just the force in the
universe I mean you die as far as I know
you didn't show up to Planet Earth with
the suitcase going I'm here like you
were born without your consent if you
think about it now some people go we
were up in a spiritual spacial thing and
we picked our parents sure but the you
that you are it does not have that
consciousness that you did that
although whatever okay so it's a force
in the universe
now again everyone's gonna go white
people aids babies I get it as long as
you have your white first world
privilege why not use it because if you
can be a miracle maker for other people
it's the best way to do that is to be
sane and stable so that I think our job
as these first world white people is to
make the world a better place we have
the most resources and so don't
pooh-pooh your spirituality because you
think well you know I'm not talking
about a literal God who looks over
people and goes I'm not helping those
aids babies I'm help that white woman in
her apartment Studio City I'm not saying
that's how it works I'm saying this if
you have the time the emotional
resources I was so devastated after my
breakup I literally thought I think you
can die from feelings I know you can't
but I was like what if what if I'm the
first one then I was like I don't care
if a truck hits me because I'm so
depressed and when I'm depressed I
sometimes get fearless because I don't
have that I have a sense of my mortality
but I don't care if that makes sense
it's not suicidal it's this other thing
where it's just like [ __ ] it I'm so
depressed who cares if I get a little
scared doing this thing I'm not even
gonna feel it anyway
and so I would lay in bed every night
and I would have to try to stop my
thoughts from going into these crazy
negative fantasies like okay my ex is
dating a 22 year old and they're in love
and he's like I hate jet-like I would
just sit there and fantasize about the
most horrible thing that could happen
that I wouldn't want and it's dumb to
get all upset over because then you have
contact with the person a year later and
they're like none of that happened and I
was working on myself all year and
you're like oh okay so I'm saying like
so then I decided why not use this time
more wisely so I would lay in bed I'm
not kidding I did this because a woman
came up to me at my show well I'll tell
you that a minute I would lay in bed
with my arms wide open I'm not kidding
I'd make a great full list before I went
to bed I don't care if you've not used
to say I have all my limbs that's every
night you can put that on a list if
interviewed and again and we've talked
about this on this podcast
some people might not have all their
limbs and I have asked limbless
listeners to write in and I didn't get
any I don't think but again you you
understand what I'm saying so if you
don't have limbs I don't mean to make
you feel bad I'm sure you're like no no
I've never known it's like it's fine
like I feel bad for you guys and like
you know how would the whole thing goes
inspirational not that everyone without
limbs is inspirational some of your
[ __ ] Oscar Pistorius or whatever
murderer right we're all good and bad
okay so I would lay in bed and I would
say universe whatever's out there I
don't mean just say I say universe
because I don't like to say God because
the people get all upset but then people
equally get upset when you sing universe
but it's pictured this way be the ball
Chevy Chase is in Caddyshack there's a
force in the universe Danny be the ball
in fact you know what I'm gonna have to
do is look up that scene so I can get
the wording right be the ball Danny hang
on sec
okay no no no no no and I'll tell you
what I did I don't know if this is um
some kind of some kind of thing that I'm
not supposed to do oh my god my friend
fortunes in an ad good work girl oh my
god why is it not playing okay I'm just
gonna I think it's so funny when Chevy
Chase is pretending it looks like he's
putting but he's really peeing and he's
barefoot all right what do want to go to
college for Danny hang on hang on is
this interesting okay Jenna's podcast
where she watches Caddyshack and says
nothing
but uh anyway all right I know I could
just look up the quotes don't be
obsessed with your desires guys the Zen
philosopher bash I once said a flute
with no holes is not a flute is this
real all right no no no no forcing
universe Danny maybe he's not doing it
okay
enforcement University I'm just going to
get the quote there's a force in the
universe that makes things happen all
you have to do is get in touch with it
stop thinking let things happen and be
the ball Oh God logins greatest song
anyway the point is everybody be the
ball okay so I'm laying in bed then my
arms open out and I go oh there's also
one of my favorite quotes is live as
though the world is tipped in your favor
because again whatever is gonna happen
is gonna happen at least our attitudes
can get us through it so Elena bend the
arms up and I said I I have a feeling
God universe force be the ball that you
want me to have a big beautiful life and
that I am stuck right I am stuck on that
it's got to be with this person I'm
stuck on that please remove that from me
and give me the big beautiful life but
make me want the big beautiful life that
you have for me and man I mean I did
that every night while sobbing not
believing in going I hate this but I did
it and I'm not saying things happen
because I did it but what I'm saying is
these things were going to happen anyway
and I could have been miserable leading
up to them or I could have been open to
it so that when they happened they felt
magical instead of like hold under one I
want and not look at why this might be a
good thing you know that kind of thing
so anyway this all goes back to when I
got a call from my agent saying there's
this woman she created Gilmore Girls you
know Amy sherman-palladino I'm like of
course she's like I think I have a new
show the marvelous mrs. Mazal they want
to have a Skype call with you and I did
it and I was just like I should have
been nervous but I was so depressed that
I wasn't nervous and so that actually
was a bonus and and so I look at that as
like lucky and then I got the job and so
I had to fly to New York and kind of
move itch there for like on and off for
six months and write on the show and
consult about some of the stand-up
performances of all the characters that
do stand-up and so did this other
comedian or no a garden smarts who's
really funny and
again like I didn't write any scripts or
anything but there were jokes here and
there and stuff like that but it was so
delightful and to get out of LA where
like it might run into your ex or
something like that and I was so mad at
New York because it was like one of the
things my ex and I would talk about like
I wanted to move back there he didn't he
was sick of it like we went to New York
one time and just had a miserable time
he was miserable being there and I was
like oh my god
I never want to go to New York again New
York you ruined my relationship and then
I was sent to live there it's like come
on that's pretty [ __ ] cool
so and then I got over it and was like
no New York is mine again and so anyway
I just felt like I can't explain to you
guys how depressed I was it was it was
if I hadn't been so depressed I would
have been frightened at how depressed I
was and anyway this great article in New
York magazine came out this week about
Amy who created marvelous mrs. Mazal and
and it's so funny because the show like
as we were doing table reads like
sometimes I would just cry cuz it's like
this guy who left this woman and she's a
stand-up and she just has her career now
no but what I learned at this job was
everyone was very kind to me I felt like
I had work to do it was um I didn't have
to be a little entrepreneur in that
moment and like think of a book to write
or think it was like I was there in
service of someone else and their idea I
learned a lot it was like getting a
graduate school education and running a
show I it was a gift it was just a
goddamn gift and so then amy was
interviewed in New York magazine she's
got amazing quotes but when I took a
picture of it is um I grew up around
comics they are not always a chipper
happy bunch if they were there would be
no comedy because comedy doesn't come
from a bunch of happy well-adjusted
people but she chooses cheerfulness over
cynicism and that I am this way - she
says I'm such a cynic I believe kittens
would kill you if they could figure out
how to get to your neck but I love the
world where my lead characters are
powering through it without that
cynicism I love the energy of female
heroines trumping through life with
their high heels and their great hair
why not have some color in your [ __ ]
life you're gonna be dead in like five
minutes
anyhow just enjoy it and wear a hat and
Amy
had these fabulous hats and um and so uh
that's how I feel and I loved that quote
from her and it was like to get to work
with someone that kind of had that
similar philosophy and not that she
cared that I had the philosophy or that
we ever discussed it but to be around
that was like exactly where I needed to
be and I'm not saying the universe
orchestrated my breakup so that I could
then have that job I'm not saying
anything I'm just saying like look at
how well things run and I get to look at
them and go oh wow I never would have no
one would have been if someone went like
okay you're gonna get dumped on
Christmas what do you want after that I
would have been like I wouldn't been
like oh to meet someone I never met just
like a groundbreaking groundbreaking
showrunner and director and then I'll
move to New York for a little while and
I'll work on this show about stand-up
and I'll be really inspired I would
never thought of that I would've been
like um what do you mean I'm gonna get
broken up with well what I want is him
to change his mind and then everything
goes back to being the same like that's
all we always want more of the same you
know if it's if if it's like you know
it's like let's make a deal like you
don't want to take a chance by what's
behind door number two no I want the
same I want the same in a lot of ways
I'm a risk-taker because I say yes to
opportunity and in a lot of ways I'm not
because I am like and so I'm really glad
that I stayed open this year and I'm not
saying that that's why things happened
but that's why I enjoyed the things that
were happening it gave me a perspective
that I could count on and that was all I
had was my perspective so anyway oh I
didn't think I'd be talking about all
that but so I'm going to New York I
decided that that's where I want to
spend Christmas and because I will have
writing to do busy businesswoman and my
dear friend from college who I was
reunited with my friend Liz we were
reunited cuz she had just moved to New
York a few months before so we had had
coffee around Christmas last year and
you know I was kind of saying to her
Mike I just feel like I'm gonna get
dumped she was like oh I'm so sorry and
you know she didn't know my ex or
anything like we hadn't been in each
other's life in a while and then I did
get dumped the next week and then I had
to go to New York I'm like Liz I'm here
and she and I hung out a lot and her
sister and and again this was my college
roommate like I always say I stole my
personality from her and became as
and it was amazing and we both changed
so much but and yet we've changed from
who we used to be but we're both still
similar again like we both like all the
same things but it's different from
before and she's just a lovely person
and we have the same kind of like
spiritual views and all I got [ __ ] so
yeah there's gonna be like a Christmas
brunch that she's putting together at a
restaurant with a bunch of people I'm
finally going on the Dyker Heights
Brooklyn Christmas light tour which I
didn't realize was like a whole thing
like I thought people are like oh just
go to Dyker Heights Brooklyn and you
know they've beautiful Christmas lights
it's like a thing there's a documentary
about it you I'm taking a bus it's like
a three and a half hour bus tour and I
got a VIP see no big deal I mean you pay
for it they weren't like oh you're a VIP
and you the houses in the neighborhood
each one spends about two to ten
thousand dollars getting it
professionally decorated and so it's
like a crazy Christmas wonderland so I'm
going by myself the night after
Christmas and not in a sad way none of
my friends are interested in paying the
money that I was willing to pay to do
this I mean I think was like 60 bucks
but people are like I don't care enough
to spend 60 so that's gonna be my gift
to myself and then yeah I'm staying in
one of my favorite hotels it's gorge I
had enough JetBlue points to fly mint on
the way there which is exciting and oh
my god if you guys fly as much as I do
and you can never get your JetBlue
points or you just want to I mean it's a
lot of money to pay for a mint see it on
its own so I wouldn't do that but I mean
it's their first class but they don't
say first class and some of the seats
are just like normal first-class seats
you sit next to someone but some are
your own little pod like a little
apartment and I love it when the plane
lands I'm like no I want to stay in the
pod so anyway I'm very looking forward
to my trip and I'm doing a really fun
show there on December 23rd at City
Winery with what Rhett Miller Janeane
Garofalo
it's his annual Christmas show that he
does and I've done it before and it's
super fun so I'm just like yay anyway so
last week I was in New York
last-minute show doing something for the
MS foundation at Caroline's and I met
Gloria Steinem and you know I was really
excited but maybe I was just being
annoying
other things to do but I am I gave her a
feminist AF necklace I think she was
kind of like huh I mean she's an 83 year
old woman after all she seems 40 but I
think she's just maybe shy like she was
just kind of quiet and dignified and
sometimes I don't really jive with those
people if that makes sense like um for
example like when I met Courtney Love I
was like oh I understand this energy
like and she wasn't coming at me all
crazy she was kind of actually sitting
there like but I could see like oh
that's someone trying to sit there
quietly who inside is buzzing and Gloria
Steinem is actually someone who's
sitting there quietly and I'm like I'm
uncomfortable and so um I she was really
nice she sat upfront and watched the
show I did some stand-up and I
referenced her a couple times on stage
probably didn't like that but she came
up to me after I just said thank you so
much it was such an honor meeting you
she goes oh I love your standup it's
like a Russian novel now I don't know I
think that's a compliment I think she
means it goes goes too long and doesn't
make sense is probably what she meant
but I think she meant it good twists and
turns I mean I haven't run it read of
Russian novels since I was a pretentious
high schooler who would take them with
me to friendlies to sit there me like
yeah Dostoyevsky [ __ ] that's how long
this is you know just holding a giant
book if there were Kindles back then I
would not have read it on one because I
need it be able to see what I was
reading I'm smoking and reading I mean I
gotta be honest with you I was not wrong
about how to live go to diners smoke and
read I only want to do that and again as
I've said I can't smoke but apparently
it's all is literally all I think about
I will never get over it and we are on
the brink of nuclear war like the brink
they are doing air raid drills in Hawaii
South Korea has never had all these Jets
do Thurs doing something Kim jong-un's
capabilities now I feel like they're
scaring us because you have to put you
have to put a nuclear bomb and for you
those of you watching the video I'm
demonstrating with a clip and a pencil
you have to put a nuclear bomb on the
stick that you sent over he's sending
the sticks over and they have
great range again they're just going in
the ocean though so it's like I feel
like we're few steps away from him
successfully nuking anything because
he's not attaching the bombs but I don't
get how it all works I feel like he has
other countries in this corner like his
Russia helping him I know they're dirt
poor so I don't know what's happening
I'm not gonna put it out of the realm of
possibility that we could get nuked and
that [ __ ] could go crazy and I honestly
feel like the world hates us so much
that everyone else would just start
nuking us like France burg I'll [ __ ]
nuke them like we're hated but and
people who sparked term don't care like
they want it that way I don't know how
to explain it like I've talked to people
that support him and they're like we
literally don't care what your thinks of
us I'm like that's insane anyway but
what was my point my I didn't have one
okay anyway oh so even then with me
knowing the world is ending I will not
start smoking again because that's how
much hope I have that I don't even know
I have it's just inherent in me and I
hate that about myself right now okay so
anyway I was talking to and so this is
what this episode was going to be and
and um why don't you guys do this why
don't you send me an email I seem fun at
gmail.com and tell me if you would
listen to this episode that I record and
I'll tell you what it is or go to the
Facebook page facebook.com slash I seem
fun facebook.com slash I seem fun
podcast and write in the comments
section of this episode so somebody had
asked me I'd love to see you kind of
Mystery Science Theater a hallmark movie
I'd love to hear you do a podcast where
you watch one and comment I get it but
what I should have done is like and
you'd have to get the rights to it in
whatever but you know like my friend
Doug Benson does Doug loves movies or
note the interruption
what's it called the movie interruption
it something like that
and you sit there and watch movies and
interrupt it but as it keeps rolling in
a giant theater and people are being
funny on microphones and it's usually a
movie people have seen before or if they
haven't they don't
here but I was watching a hallmark movie
cold like one I'd never seen and trying
to describe to you guys what was going
on and I I mean I suppose some of the
things I said we're funny but there was
no time to make jokes it was just like I
have to tell you what's going on but I'd
have to listen to and so I don't know
what I was thinking it's like an hour
and a half long podcast there are some
funny moments in it of course like I
might sidebar for a second I started to
get the hang of it after a while but I
started to listen to it I was like I
cannot release this and tell them it's a
podcast like I might have to release it
as a bonus because I don't even know but
I was just like okay so there's what's
that guy's name okay so he's making toys
and his brothers like this I mean I
don't think it's very good and I were an
advertiser I'd be like no so we're gonna
see what's gonna happen with that but
write me and let me know if you want to
hear it because it's a great movie it's
about a busy woman who is a professional
organizer who helps a widowed toymaker
dad organize his life and the toymaker
I mean he's not just some idiot who's
making toys he runs a company with his
brother his brother is a suit-and-tie
type and this guy Bobby is like I love
toys and you know his wife's dead his
kids the head of the superstore like a
Walmart is coming to see if those guys
could be in business with him and a next
year they could have toys for sale in
his store and weirdly the superstore guy
is all about family and they make him a
family dinner and it's his wife's a
vegetarian everyone's freaking out I
really think you'll want to know about
this movie but let me know if you if I
should release that episode I will only
do it by popular demand so you know
where to find me to let me know about
that but what I've been doing all month
is this is the holiday themed month like
it or not and I'm in reading emails from
people the ongoing controversy of if
diehard is a Christmas movie and
everybody talking about their favorite
things I have so many emails here it's
reading so I'm just gonna take it from
here and we'll do a few of those as well
I think I forgot to talk about the
we got my annual conversation with my
mom about the Beatles at Thanksgiving
there was some family drama this year I
won't get into it I was very sad it was
possibly on a crying jag for a little
while just just can't take no one in my
family is like talking about Trump or
like forcing it on me but there's just
little things here and there that I'm
just like I feel things have changed
because of him and I'm not gonna get
into it but washing dishes with my mom
and we're talking about the Beatles you
know she's not in the digital age she's
not iTunes or Spotify please um but she
was talking about you know she stills
their Beatles albums I'm like do Vinny
on CD I got to the White Album cd1 s--
and she was like no I'm like so you know
I just put on I tune my I have every
Beatles album not to brag and so we're
big fans and in the Kirkman family well
me my mom our and we were listening
while we were doing dishes and she gets
on her thing it's like if you you would
think that we were having an argument
about Trump she gets so mad at me when I
make fun of Ringo Starr he is peace and
love Jennifer you stop doing Jennifer
why do you say because it's Howard Stern
fans know they love playing that YouTube
clip of Ringo Starr's saying after
October 22nd I have too much to do I am
selling my things with peace and love
peace and love and he sounds angry
and I was telling my mom and I went to
the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame in
Cleveland big bummer and the guy there
was like you just miss Ringo Starr's
drum set like the original one from the
Beatles he came here to pick it up he's
selling it like what like that's such a
weird image to me that like you know the
way that my mom was trying to pawn off
old Christmas decorations on me like
this is from when you were a baby and
I'm like taking it home like Ringo Starr
like I'm just picturing him physically
coming in and picking up like a bass
drum and just schlepping it back to
wherever and I've heard he's like
selling all his stuff and I'm like does
he have no money and then um you know
but I was like nobody was in the Beatles
misuk he was the drummer people and I
just read um oh my god and I gotta get
her on four they seemed fun because
she's wonderful is Patti Schemmel from
the band
her book hit so hard she's an amazing
drummer she's an amazing person and she
has that's a good read
that's especially if you're a 90s person
it's real detailed about her whole life
playing with whole living with Kurt and
Courtney all that stuff but then beyond
that it's her story before and after
those moments of course of being a
drummer of losing it all the drug
addiction and just I mean you know every
once in a while like you have the people
that are famous for their problems with
addiction and you're like and then
Michael Jackson comes in and like trumps
everybody it's like oh that was the that
that was the hardest going of all guys
doing propofol at night you know we
talked about Elvis with his pills and um
in that way like Patti and I'm sure
she's glad for is not known for her
addiction I think in the general sense
of the world and she had a bat and it
was like the recovery stories in here
are great see the attempts the how many
times oh my god it's just it's
heartbreaking but you can really see
where people start to spiral and they
just can't stop so her book is amazing
and and you already know that has a
happy ending because she's got an
amazing life and she did a documentary
called hit so hard and this book is like
the way more detailed version of that so
that's a good Christmas read if you're
not going to get my book I can barely
take care of myself which you should
give to friends who don't want kids I
think that's also a good holiday game
day gift anyway so in Patti's book she
was talking about how much money the
drummer makes and I was like oh my god
it was like you could make more a year
probably like working retail probably
like it literally when she was on hole
one on hole on tour with hole or like
when they were making this album or
that's like wait that's all you got and
so you know and she was like yeah like
the drummer's get screwed and they're
easily replaceable even though they're
not but people think of them that way
and whatever so it's like you might so
anyway it's like I don't know how much
Ringo got for like tours and stuff and
obviously they haven't been together in
decades so it's not like how long does
that tour money last and he doesn't have
any songwriting rights and you know
maybe he did his own thing but I don't
know I don't know how
let me look up Ringo Starr's net worth
although these things are wrong it says
that my friend Chris friend jewel is
worth 18 million I was like do they mean
pennies and um and mine isn't accurate
either oh but he had Ringo in the
all-star band his net worth as of April
2017 was 350 million oh okay well he's
probably fine but even if that's off by
a hundred million even if it's off by
two hundred and fifty million now Paul
McCartney is only worth 660 million I
thought he'd be a billionaire so what
that's weird
anyway okay so I don't know Ringo is
pretty rich but I don't know why he's
selling everything but my mom's Inc has
saw him in his band at Foxwoods casino
he is the nicest person and he said John
liked him best
is it once everyone's dead you really he
liked me best John's not gonna come back
and dispute it he is peace and love he
is not angry in you of being human being
awful he is peace and love and so then
we start talking to my mom hates Paul
McCartney and and hates a strong word
but I he's not my thing either
and I just I just again I've said this
before I don't like when he gets all
doodly-doo in the middle of an already
going well Beatles song that's like edgy
and he's like do put up a duel or Aaron
gets all ragtime about it it makes me
insane and so hang on mmm and so my mom
was saying I'm a John Lennon girl I mean
I just like his look I mean that's what
it comes down to we're talking about
were two girls talking about what look
we prefer now my dad looks something
like John Lennon but I guess I would be
my mom's you know free pass or whatever
not free pass I think my mom would have
fully run off with John Lennon not like
hey let's just have a one-night stand
and um I talked her down from some Yoko
Ono hey someone's not too internalized
sexism Yoko was a big part of John
Lennon's peace and love transformation
it wasn't just um you know going to
India and all that stuff
uh yeah and she was just like I don't
know what it is about Paul he's too
square he's too much of a goody-goody
and I'm like mom they all lived pretty
hard like you know even Paul and she was
like I don't know why I forgive the
Beatles for everything you know I don't
look down on them for all they did that
was maybe bad because they were young
and they didn't know and and um as well
John London was sort of an [ __ ] to
women you know he was abusive I know but
then he turned his life around I mean
she is I don't know anyway my whole
point is it was a manual discussion and
I don't even know if my mom knows about
the song simply having a wonderful
christmastime but I'm not gonna ruin her
life and tell her about it so anyway um
let's see okay
this guy jack is writing about the
listener who said he wanted to act gay
in order to compliment a woman's shoes I
knew this was gonna come I thought I had
given a very nuanced answer that
included like what does act gay mean
anyway but like we know what he meant
we meant like a Three's Company hey girl
like that's what we met at gay which
would be offensive to gay people but in
the context of what we were talking
about just everybody calm down so this
guy's reading me the riot act he's
really disappointed i won he said you
read a listener email about a straight
guy who asked if it's alright to act gay
in order to compliment a woman's shoes
is a longtime listener big fan of yours
and as a gay man myself
I find this somewhat problematic I'm
disappointed that you basically gave him
permission to do this without examining
how this may seem a little condescending
to men who are actually gay Jack I'm
sorry you felt that way I thought it was
implied that this was a completely silly
email and that of course I don't think
there is a way to act gay I never know
who's gay and the only time I do know is
when someone is stereotypically like hi
and I'm in West Hollywood and they're
doing like snap snap this email was to
just I thought it was funny and I'm
taking it out of the realm
being so on top of not political
correctness but like outrage culture all
the time like sometimes somebody can say
something ridiculous like that and my
answer because I thought it would be
just a ridiculous point of views like
sure act gay whatever that means like
but there is a gay way to act Jack and
you know that that's true I know you're
a gay man but there is a stereotypical
gay way to act based on stereotypes and
that that is yes that's what I was
giving that man permission to do all
under the guise of this whole thing is
[ __ ] ridiculous you don't need to
yell at a woman about her shoes he said
he would pose this question to the
listener how would he act gay when he
talked with a high-pitched voice
peppered with queer eye straight guy
Lisp how would he pretend to signal to a
woman that he was gay it seems like he
isn't comfortable in his own masculinity
to simply compliment people on their
fashion choices in a way that wouldn't
be perceived as creepy see Jack this is
where you need education there is no way
for a man to talk to a woman that
doesn't seem creepy we decide what seems
creepy you can say in the least creepy
way possible I like your shoes but if
we're in a situation that it seems
inappropriate to say that if we we don't
know what men are safe and what men are
not that's my [ __ ] point
unless they are outrageously gay acting
we don't know what men are safe and what
men are not so Jack while you're trying
to read me the riot act your thing is
problematic where you just said he
should be able to compliment someone
without being perceived as creepy no
Jack that's not up to him to decide I
have had men come up to me being totally
normal and I am afraid because I have
been eight out of ten encounters has
ended up with me being nice to someone
and then thinking that they can hit on
me or I'm alone in a parking garage and
it's weird and Jack you're not right
about that you've even said on your
podcast previously that people should
replace words like woman with black to
see if they're saying as construed as
offensive if I asked you gee I sure
would like to compliment the black
barista on her hair but I know black
people are sensitive is it okay for me
to pretend to be black to compliment
black people's hair of course not no
Jack of course not but you can't protect
me I guess you could pretend to be black
sure but in that instance I would have
said the same thing because it was a
joking situation that I was
I was like yes act gay like I can't
explain it to you if you weren't in on
the kind of the whole scenario to me it
was a [ __ ] joke and so my whole point
was that I was going to educate this guy
about the real underlying issue of the
email was that he needs to talk to women
so badly he needs to give his opinion so
badly that he would go so far as to act
gay whatever that means and so I was
giving him permission to do it
because it was under the umbrella of
this whole thing is [ __ ] ridiculous
so Jack I'm sorry I disappointed you I'm
sorry that you don't think more of me
than to know that I totally understand
that and we'll just have to agree to
disagree about that segment of my show
how long have I been doing here in seven
hours
okay we've ten minutes left can I do 10
minutes okay
so this email die-hard Anthony hey Jen
loved the Houston show okay great
favorite Christmas movie Emmet's other
jug-band Christmas what is that oh and
it otter does it emit other who is that
it's um it's a Disney like puppet
Christmas it's old
oh this guy goes it's a childhood fave
I'm showing my age by saying this over
your child of the 80s it's a I mean I've
seen it I haven't I've never heard of it
favorite Christmas song being Bowie Bing
Crosby a little drummer boy or John
Lennon Yoko Ono happy Christmas more is
over thank you I just played that tour
is over if you want Trump is over if you
want Lee's favorite Christmas song that
annoying Sir Paul McCartney used to say
Sir Paul McCartney Wings song whose name
I can't recall it's called simply having
a wonderful Christmas time but the fact
that it's going through my head is
making me turn on my white noise up my
new tradition is probably going to be
going hiking on Christmas because I just
moved to Houston and it'll be a present
to myself
then I'll go have a drink and I heart is
not a Christmas film but planes trains
and automobiles should have nope no
Thanksgiving it's a Thanksgiving movie
they're going home for Thanksgiving yeah
yeah people you people just meet there's
anarchy going on out there
and I blame Trump people are making up
their own [ __ ] here's another oh this is
from Kate the first woman not the first
woman but the first woman to have this
opinion not to assume someone named Kate
is a woman okay yes I think it's a
Christmas movie at its heart it's a
romantic tale of love with
misunderstandings miracles a busy
businesswoman and heartwarming human
connections with Christmas decorations
in many scenes and also Christmas music
huh
wait it's it's about love well he's
estranged from his wife oh and his
children because she moved to LA for a
career do they get back together in the
end of the first two yeah well I get
what she's saying it sounds like it's an
action-adventure film that has the heart
of a romantic comedy I guess or do you
think it's still more about bad guys
it's more about that
okay then Kate sorry it just takes place
at a Christmas party Kate you're wrong
her favorite Christmas song John Lennon
happy Christmas oh my god everyone and I
like that this is happy Christmas I
think it's cool that's like a way to be
cool for sure and I I think Yoko Ono
came up with wars over if you want it so
everyone who hates Cape on hey and I
really do love her I'm guilty pleasure
Christmas song Britney Spears my only
wish this year I don't know that one you
know that Mariah Carey song and when the
Christmas I know no oh [ __ ] that's in my
head constantly and the lyrics I'm
getting wrong but I'm going in my head
everyone's a Christmas tree favorite
Christmas movie elf is the one I watch
most or Christmas vacation yep least
favorite Christmas movie It's a
Wonderful Life I just realized it's one
there's there's there's four movies that
I've seen more than 40 times they are
cabaret Annie Hall Caddyshack and it's a
Wonderful Life
I think technically those are my four
favorite movies yeah white woman central
on that one I understand and I don't
watch any holiday more because Eddie
Eddie Eddie Allen just creep Eddie Allen
just
reaps me out now Woody Allen now I had a
rule that I don't think he'd molested
anyone before he made that movie but I
just looking at his face now bothers me
yeah because I'm always like it's okay
to listen to like pre thriller Michael
Jackson if we're going on like when they
molested people mm-hmm sure now I don't
know when Michael did or didn't anyway
probably say anything before bad I would
think Oh hundred-percent bad after bad I
thinks when things actually got bad
that's the alman was secretly he was
telling us well he did say he said I'm
bad you know it
he didn't mean like bad ass he meant
like peppers okay I've only watched it
once when I was in grade school but I
found it so upsetting depressing that I
refused to ever watch it again I don't
understand how people love it so much
maybe try try it again especially under
the umbrella of like Trump and mr.
Potter and it's I mean I can get behind
a movie about a guy who's gonna kill
himself and then doesn't like the the
acting is so incredible Jimmy Stewart is
just such a brilliant actor and I wasn't
gonna watch that movie again because I
went to see it with my ex on Christmas
Eve at the theater and I was like it's
gonna remind me of him no it's not it's
gonna remind me of me and how much I
loved that goddamn movie and how I cry
oh my god I can make myself cry the two
things that make me cry happy tears are
actually happy Christmas Mort was over I
just start like getting all emotional
and at the end when they're like the
teacher says when a bell rings an angel
gets its wings and George Bailey yelling
Merry Christmas you building a loan I
always said if I had an It's a Wonderful
Life moment in my life because I was
just traveling again this weekend and
it's the same thing with these I found
out I have a bad lift rating but it's
because I've been I'm not talkative to
the dudes in the car and I won't answer
personal questions so I think they've
given me bad ratings because I was
tipped 30% and I always am on time but
this year I was literally on the phone
like I'm writing this script I'm getting
notes from the studio I'm like I can
talk between 440 and 450 when I'm in the
car and I would get a call and I'd be
like okay so in this scenes you should
do this okay great I'll adjust that and
literally the lyft drivers like where
are you from I'm like would you shut the
[ __ ] up and in this women so anyway I
get so angry I'm like stop asking me but
where they're from or why they're
travelling it's invasive just be quiet
like wit get back to old-fashioned
chauffeuring chauffeuring or if you do
talk just to not ask people personal
questions but I think in my version of
It's a Wonderful Life where I'm driven
to almost jump off a bridge because of
lyft drivers and all that and people are
like what was the underlying thing and
then everyone knows means like knows
literally because of that I jump off I
get saved and at the end of the movie
when I'm running around going Merry
Christmas like this is George Bailey I'm
gonna play this for you guys oh why
these ads are driving me crazy I don't
want the video to play for the ad I want
to be able to skip ahead and do what I
want to do a girl's gonna do what she
wants to do hang on one sec he's so
happy he's not dead
Merry Christmas Merry Christmas lyft
drivers he's just saying merry Christmas
to buildings Merry Christmas
uber Merry Christmas lyft drivers Merry
Christmas
people that check me in at the hotel and
asked me why I'm in town
Merry Christmas people at customs who
asked me if I'm really a comedian and
why they've never heard of me Merry
Christmas that's me and at the end of my
movie we're because I almost died I I
suddenly I'm so grateful for things I
wasn't grateful for before and then the
next day I go back to being like
whatever alright well you know I think
we're gonna end there maybe one more
quick email we'll see what people say so
I guess we're not ending there these are
some of my favorite things favorite
Christmas carols angels we have heard on
high joy to the world this this woman is
a Virgo Michelle oh and her email
addresses has the word library in it so
sorry that was probably too much
information but she has like bullet
point outlines favorite Christmas carol
a parenthesis s traditional
angels we have heard on high joy to the
world silent night modern I'll be home
for Christmas
sweet sweet sweet secret piece by Neil
Flynn winter song by Ingrid Michaelson
and Sara Bareilles then least favourite
Christmas carols traditional the little
drummer boy modern Christmas shoes it
needs to die in a fire last week someone
loved Christmas shoes Carol that makes
me cry Judy Garland sings have yourself
a merry little Christmas and meet me in
st. Louis at Rex me now that's a movie
I've never seen and don't give a [ __ ] to
see do not care do not care and I love
the Judy Garland but that song makes me
sad and it's because I had this ice
skate to it once by myself as a little
kid because I got invited to a very
popular girl's birthday party and they
were like couples skating not couples
like relationships but like partner up
and it was an odd number of people and I
didn't get out there and I sat by myself
to that and I know I didn't even like
this girl I just had to go to her party
and then that memory probably isn't even
true it's probably like I realize now
half my memories are probably made up um
favorite traditional Christmas movie
Charlie Brown Christmas holiday in - the
racist bits yep little women little
woman's a Christmas movie I think then
we're getting into diary territory
favorite Christmas movies modern the ref
what is a Christmas movie yeah really
yeah Scrooged I mean that is while you
were sleeping with Sandra block yeah I
like to say block I don't know if that
is not we'll see oh [ __ ] I forgot to
watch Love Actually and then lastly
least favorite Christmas movies Frosty
the Snowman I never liked that either
and modern Love Actually
Merry Christmas oh yeah she says she's a
librarian well I love it thank you for
weighing in on that I don't know what I
don't know about the ref well I've never
seen it but I have strong opinions on
things that I haven't even seen all
right well hang on now I'm just reading
people's emails why can't I ever end
this normal I can never end this
normally okay until next week have fun
oh I forgot to do ads we'll just
interrupt the program and do them all in
a row it's okay to do them all in a row
right
yeah bill burr does it oh yeah kill the
video killed the radio star